bonsoir à tous votre soirée spéciale
municipal se poursuit effectivement en
bourgogne avec les premiers résultats
dans les minutes à venir à nevers à
auxerre ou montceau les mines
mais d'abord voyons qui nous a rejoint
sur ce plateau nous inviter en direct
nous sommes avec philippe baumel bonsoir
député socialiste de saône et loire et
conseiller municipal du breuil également
rémy de la tête avec nous bonsoir soit
député maire ump de saint-apollinaire et
lui vaut aussi au premier tour la
semaine dernière edouard cavens bonsoir
bonsoir tête de liste du front national
pour la ville de dijon nous vous
donnerons des chiffres également pour
dijon assez rapidement dans les
prochaines minutes les chiffres c'est la
faire d'elles a besoin ce soir encore
tous les résultats minute par minute
à suivre en direct et puis pour
décortiquer décrypter analyser ces
chiffres et ces résultats et lilian
melet et eric sicaud sont avec nous
également nous allons prendre tout de
suite la direction de nevers nous attend
régis guillon régis pour un résultat
déjà définitif sur la ville de nevers me
semble-t-il
bonsoir régis bonsoir et bien écoutez
oui je suis en mesure de vous l'annoncer
officiellement ce soir florent sainte
fare garnot le maire ps sortant de
nevers est battu il est battu par la
liste emmenée par denis thuriau listes
indépendantes à laquelle s'est ralliée
s'est ralliée durant l'entre-deux-tours
l'ump et lui dit alors voici quels sont
les chiffres la liste thuriau totalise
49 80 % des voix la liste ps pc les
verts totalisent 40 2% des voix et enfin
la liste front national elle totalise
8,20 % puisque nous avions affaire à une
triangulaire ici à nevers alors cette
défaite de la gauche ici c'est une page
qui se tourne vous savez nevers bastion
socialiste depuis 43 ans ne versaient
bien sûr pierre bérégovoy c'est l'ombre
portée de françois mitterrand et 7 ce
soir une nouvelle claque que prend la
gauche après après avoir perdu
cosne-sur-loire au premier tour après
avoir perdu corby nîmes cerci nevers
donc qui eux basculent ce soir et
maire sortant qui viendra s'exprimer
dans quelques instants florent sainte
fare garnot a rejoint la préfecture avec
ses colistiers vous appelez évidemment
dès qu'ils arrivent à vos côtés merci
régis lille hermerel melet première
grosse surprise de ce début de soirée
oui alors c'est une des grandes
questions de ce deuxième tour on l'a
abordée dans notre débat de jeudi soir
sur france 3 bourgogne
parce qu'il y avait eu une
redistribution des cartes total avec
cette alliance entre en tout cas le fait
que les candidats de l'ump du déni et
rejoint denis thuriau et on se posait
cette question
on sait que denis thériault est un
ancien membre du parti socialiste la
question c'est est est ce que cette
alliance va fonctionner est ce que un
certain nombre d'électeurs proche de la
gauche vont quitter cette alliance on va
dire en voyant arriver des candidats de
droite bat clairement non denis thuriau
à augmenter encore son nombre de voix
par rapport au premier tour donc
manifestement ce cette alliance a
fonctionné florent sainte fare garnot il
a gagné des électeurs aussi mais pas
suffisamment dans ce contexte on sait
qu'il est difficile pour la gauche
quand on parlait de symboles on disait
quarante trois ans on va se rappeler
aussi que le 1er mai 2012 une des
dernière visite de françois hollande
avant son élection
c'était à nevers donc on peut mesurer
l'ampleur de ce qui se passe en ce
moment avec juste une question car oui
ou non la question quand même composera
denis curieux quand il sera là c'est est
ce qu'on doit dire que la ville de
nevers ce soir n'est plus à gauche parce
que denis curio est un candidat sans
étiquette
il a été rejoint par des candidats de
droite il ne devra nous le dire lui-même
parce que pour l'instant on ne sait pas
alors la ville analyse peut-être de
philippe baumel ont écouté d'abord j'ai
une pensée pour les socialistes des
verts qui ont quand même eu et je crois
à se battre jusqu'au dernier moment pour
essayer de convaincre les gens arrivent
à venir voter je crois que le bilan sur
nevers n'était pas si mauvais que ça je
pense évidemment que le vent qui souffle
se vendent bleus en quelque sorte
eh bien les a rattrapés fortement et
c'est vrai que l'échec est symbolique
parce que nevers sépare anodin dans
l'histoire de des socialistes
particulièrement région bourgogne
bon alors j'ai la même interrogation que
vous moi je voudrais qu'on arrive à
préciser
de quelqu'un vient ce monsieur est
finalement calé jusqu'au bout son projet
politique d'où il vient on sait bien que
c'est tout ce qu'on sait on ne sait pas
aujourd'hui quelle est sa configuration
ans quelle que soit leur nouvelle nous
verrons bien comment les choses se
préciseront m'a fait moi je vais pas
nier les choses c'est un cruel revers
ce qu'il est intéressant de noter en
tout cas c'est que florent sainte fare
garnot compter sur les voix de gauche
qui s'étaient portées sur le candidat
denis thuriau au premier tour et qui
aurait pu retourner vers lui au second
ce qui n'a pas été le cas même si tous
les deux gagne des voix et notamment
florent sainte fare garnot on gagne
beaucoup plus que lui mais pas triste
voilà je vais vous dire il ya une très
forte progression qui est du résultat en
voie de du maire sortant que l'emea
chapleau ville va ça ne suffit pas mais
là on va retrouver une problématique
nationale qui est celle de l'abstention
aussi une abstention qui est d'abord à
gauche et qu'il va falloir analyser
jusqu'au bout c'est une nouvelle claque
pour le parti socialiste la midinette
c'est une claque je crois
qu'effectivement c'est une sanction au
niveau national comme au niveau régional
et local une sanction pour le parti
socialiste c'est surtout une solution
pour françois hollande croit que les
français ne veulent plus de la politique
proposée par françois hollande est là le
propos que tenait mon collègue philippe
baumel et un instant montre bien à quel
point certains socialistes sont
désemparés et sont en recherche d'une
autre solution
preuve en est sûre nous vers nevers qui
a un grand symbole en bourgogne grand
symbole de la gauche et qui
effectivement vient d'échapper aux
socialistes le maire sortant florent
sainte fare garnot battu donc ce soir
est en direct depuis et nevers nous
allons le retrouver bon soir florent
sainte fare garnot on évoquer la
situation de nevers où tout a changé
entre les deux tours oui manifestement
l'alliance des droites à fonctionner à
nos vert le vert est tombé à droite je
le dis avec une grande tristesse ce soir
c'est la vie c'est la vie démocratique
et de respect des urnes et le respect
des noeuds vers soi je pense à
l'évidence que ces alliances contre
nature mais aussi un contexte national
où on produit sur résultats mais je suis
là devant vous avec l' envie de
continuer à travailler pour nos verts
demeurent bien sûr vous vous considérez
que la ville de nevers est désormais à
droite même si denis thuriau faisait
partie des rangs socialistes il ya
encore quelques mois le débat pendant
cette élection a suffisamment fait
émerger je crois une réalité c'est que
monsieur thuriau n'est plus à gauche il
a dit très fort à de nombreuses reprises
il a fait une première partie de
campagne en indiquant qu'ils étaient
apolitiques et comme disait françois
mitterrand quand on n'est pas de gauche
on se dit parfois à politique pour ne
pas dire qu'on est de droite et la
fusion au deuxième tour avec l'ump me
paraît suffisamment clair pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de débat sur ce point et je ne
vois pas du tout dur est l'utilité d'en
discuter réellement c'est un fait il est
respectable
sur le plan politique c'est un fait le
vote sanction s'est exprimé une verre
malheureusement est passé à droite c'est
la première fois que vous affrontiez les
lésions de florent sainte fare garnot
votre avenir vous lisez vous allez
continuer à avancer pour la ville de
nevers sous quelle forme simplement
d'abord je vais prendre mon bâton de
pèlerin en tant que opposant opposants
constructifs j'aime ne versent une ville
magnifique
j'ai installé ma famille j'ai bien
l'intention de continuer à oeuvrer pour
les noeuds vers soi je suis déçu bien
sûr
je pense aussi aux 42 % de versoix qui
ont voté pour la liste que j'ai menée
devant eux
j'aurai les remercier et remercier aussi
mes colistiers qui sont à mes côtés
nous avons fait une campagne digne ça
n'a pas nécessairement été le cas de
tous donc je voudrais vraiment le dire
le marquer et voilà j'aime nevers c'est
une ville magnifique
je suis jeune et donc je n'abandonnerai
pas les neuf et reçoit un mot florent
sainte fare garnot sur le contexte
national est ce que vous avez senti
cette pression d'un contexte national
qui vous étaient très défavorables n'ont
bizarrement pendant le premier tour
nous avons eu une discussion extrêmement
sereine avec les neuf et reçoit ils ne
nous ont pas dit nettement leur volonté
de marquer la sanction au gouvernement
c'est assez étonnant parce que nous
avons une liberté de parole mutuel mais
ils n'ont pas dit les choses au premier
tour ils les ont dit
entre les deux tours mais avec en même
temps beaucoup de jeu le dit hein c'est
un c'est comme ça ça peut paraître
étonnant mais c'est comme ça avec
beaucoup de sympathie à notre égard
disant voilà on aime votre travail ça se
passe bien à nevers continuer mais je
crois objectivement que l'alliance qui a
été fait qui est un peu contre nature
après une partie des électeurs de gauche
pour les emmener sur une liste de droite
et ça a produit l'effet que que je
regrette mais qu'en tant que républicain
que je respecte les symboles que là que
la droite passe à nevers et prennent
cette ville de nevers vous le percevez
comme cela aussi
oui on va pas faire semblant c'est un
symbole à l'évidence c'est un une ville
qui a le coeur à gauche et qui à mon
sens du reste là toujours qui va sans
doute se réveiller avec la gueule de
bois deux ans demain mais c'est ainsi
c'est la démocratie et c'est un symbole
à l'évidence du fait que le gouvernement
le pays la france face à la crise
souffre et que sa souffrance s'exprime
dans les urnes c'est aussi fait pour ça
une élection même si c'est difficile
lorsqu'on est maire est con on pense en
toute modestie avec son équipe à avoir
oeuvré pour l'intérêt général il faut
l'accepter c'est ainsi merci florent
sainte fare garnot pour cette réaction
directe sur france 3 florent sainte fare
garnot donc battu à nevers denis thuriau
nous entendrons sa réaction dans les
prochaines minutes également sur france
3 la ville de nevers bascule à droite
quand est-il d'auxerre nous prenons la
direction de la préfecture de l'yonne
avec nathalie baffert nathalie gif et
reiz face à guillaume larrivé c'était
très serré au premier tour qu'en est il
pour ce deuxième tour
alors ce fut également très serré mais
c'est finalement donc guy ferrer qui
l'emportent avec 51,13 % face à l'ump
guillaume larrivé 48,87 et le durant
tout le dépouillement ces restes
serrés puisque seuls 312 voix séparent
les deux candidats
c'est en quelque sorte la revanche de
2012 au guillaume larrivé l'avait
emporté lors des législatives
et ce soir donc guy ferrer reprend la
main et obtient donc un troisième mandat
à auxerre autres résultats à joigny où
la gauche reste
avec bernard moraine 49 68 % devant
françois jacquet 40 2,14 et claude
dassier 8 17
bernard moraine réélu donc à joigny et
puis cette autre résultat à tonnerre ou
cette fois-ci tonnerre passe à droite
avec la candidate dominique aguilar son
étiquette mais à droite 36 40 % devant
pascal lenoir le candidat de gauche 33
65 et enfin devant bernard clément 29,95
merci nathalie indirects d'auxerre à
lilian melet sur cette situation à
auxerre alors avancèrent tonnerre
d'abord qui n'est pas vraiment une
surprise parce qu'il ya une succession
donc une situation rendue plus difficile
et puis tonnerre une ville très
fluctuantes selon les alternances
politiques parce qu'elle est vraiment si
tu es on l'a déjà dit la semaine
dernière dans une zone un peu tampon
dans les influences de l'yonne entre le
nord et le sud jouanny bas bernard
moraine confirme on se rappelle que
joannie c'était un fief historique de la
droite avec philippe auberger qui est
réputé a fait cinq mandats ça a basculé
sur une division une guerre civile à
droite absolument terrible la dernière
fois il ya une annulation d'élection
bernard moraine il a été élu sur ces
entrefaites et là il confirme bernard
moraine dans cette ville il y avait eu
une bascule étonnante il était en avance
sur les bureaux historique de la droite
à joannie bernard moraine non lui il a
vraiment réussi son ancrage dans la
ville de joigny et puis auxerre bat
c'était l'autre interrogation bien sûr
on va avoir le temps d'en reparler je
pense avec les avec les interlocuteurs
guillaume larrivé très marquée
politiquement très marquée à l'ump qui a
fait une campagne qui a commencé très
tôt il s'est déclaré il ya plus d'un an
maintenant différait ce qu'est un maire
un peu particulier par rapport à
d'autres puisqu'il n'a pas d'autre
mandat
il a vraiment toujours jouer cette
présence forte sur auxerre la situation
était rendue difficile on en parlera
peut-être avec édouard cavens tout à
l'heure pour la gauche parce que le
front national a raté de peu la
qualification pour le deuxième tour et
donc manifestement il a réussi guy
ferrer a mobilisé sur un certain nombre
de bureaux
ce qui ne sera pas passer partout mais
qui s'est manifestement passé à auxerre
de 300 voix d'écart entre guillaume
larrivé et guy ferrer prend la direction
de montceau les mines à présent nous
attend stéphane robert pour un résultat
définitif là aussi le maire socialiste
sortant était en danger
didier mathus où en est-on glam et vous
le résultat définitif stéphane
bonsoir en or bonsoir à tous ces coups t
il ya plein de monde ici dans la salle
du conseil municipal de la mairie les
résultats viennent d'être annoncées par
didier mathus lui même didier mathus
battu avec 40% des voix pour sa liste
contre 50% pour marie claude jarrot le
candidat du front national il y en noir
au qui a à peu près 9 % pour sa liste du
front national il est déjà assuré de
siéger au conseil municipal alors chaude
ambiance ici dans la mairie de montceau
les mines
puisqu'il y a les pros et antis mathus
et jaro est du coup les uns se répondent
aux autres avec des applaudissements et
des huées en tout cas ce que l'on sait
c'est que marie claude jarrot arrive
avec 700 voix d'avancé sur didier mathus
didier mathus qui ce soir à paraître
suppléante de christophe sirugue à
l'assemblée nationale n'a plus de mandat
ni nationale donc ni locale merci
stéphane à tout à l'heure avant de
prendre des nouvelles de dijon questions
à philippe baumel encore un bastion de
la gauche jacky qui bascule film mène
oui c'est juste c'est juste moi nous
l'expliqué la barre et j'y vois très
sincèrement la confusion qu'à générer
une politique nationale qui a été
largement incomprise
on va pas se cacher derrière notre petit
doigt ce soir je veux dire la claque est
monumentale donc il faut regarder en
face la réalité il ya une partie de
l'électorat de gauche qui a flotté
bigrement je ne vois pas ce que je le
dis sincèrement je pense que je voudrais
connaît un débat de vérité ce soir je ne
vois pas quand on regarde en nombre de
voix de progression significative de
l'opposition quelle qu'elle soit je le
dis je je le dis parce que c'est une
secte malheureusement pour nous tous
d'ailleurs la cruauté des chiffres c'est
qu'en vérité l'abstention elle a mordu
largement à gauche parce que je pense
qu'une partie de l'électorat de gauche
porte ce depuis depuis un certain nombre
de semaines une forme de désespoir et ça
il faut l'analyser jusqu'au bout il faut
que cela est un certain nombre de
réactions en gens dans cette direction
dès demain et je pense que dès demain
probablement en région mais aussi plus
un peu plus haut à paris au parlement
notamment il y aura des réactions vives
on ne peut pas continuer sur cette
ligne-là c'est-à-dire une ligne floue
qui sur tout un tas de sujets évoluant
plus en fonction des circonstances
on a besoin d'eux chef d'un récit
d'objectifs clairs et ona deuxième donc
de s'engager sur un chemin relativement
balisé furter parlementaire vous allez
dire quoi demain écoutez moi je
travaille au jeu depuis depuis
malheureusement déjà quelques jours a
depuis les résultats du premier tour qui
ne s'en sentent qu'ils dont on sentait
bien qu'il allait se vérifier au
deuxième nous travaillons à la
constitution d'un groupe de
parlementaires qui va poser un certain
nombre de conditions sur cette nombre de
réformes à venir parce que on ne peut
pas continuer avec ces termes de réforme
à la fois incomprise et souvent quand
même avec des aspects particulièrement
cruelle sur des catégories sociales des
plus faibles
soyez dans ses campagnes électorales
beaucoup de nos amis politiques sont
partis avec bien peu de choses dans la
musette
je pense par exemple aux retraités pour
lesquels sincèrement on n'avait pas
beaucoup d'arguments positifs
je pense aussi aux jeunes et notamment
aux jeunes dans les quartiers quand on
regarde de près l'évolution de
l'abstention dans les quartiers on voit
que précisément ils se sont en partie à
6 mai pour personne ils sont restés chez
eux
donc tout ça ça a du sens il faut
l'analyser il faut infléchir la ligne
politique
une question et de lattes marie claude
jarrot qui est conseillère régionale ump
elle avait fait le choix à montceau
d'avoir une liste sans étiquette
politique un certain nombre de gens qui
l'ont fait et avant l'élection s'était
manifestement la tendance de se dire
c'est pas sûr que ce soit très porteur
non plus qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous savez une élection municipale c'est
très particulier c'est déjà une équation
entre les électeurs et un homme une
équipe un projet une méthode et
j'observe que est effectivement eu au
premier tour là où il ya eu cette
équation cette confiance entre les
électeurs et des candidats
il ya eu une élection sans appel
naturellement au niveau national on a
des grandes des grandes figures je pense
à alain juppé eric woerth
christian jacob ici localement on a eu
aussi hubert brigand alain suguenot
d'autres d'autres encore y compris dans
les petites communes et ça ça se vérifie
toujours
et puis après il ya effectivement la
proche politique et de fait on sent bien
une sanction au niveau national sanction
de la politique de monsieur hollande
contrairement à ce que dit mon collègue
la politique et des ailes et très bien
comprise de nos concitoyens et
simplement il n'y adhèrent pas et
président de la république est
aujourd'hui face à une réalité où il est
désavoué il faut aujourd'hui qu'ils
changent de politique
alors effectivement certains n'avaient
pas souhaité conduire des listes
politique c'est mon cas de ma commune je
n'ai pas une liste politique de ma
commune mais il ya un vrai une vraie
confiance entre les premiers et moi-même
preuve en est ils ont été à 78 83 % à se
porter donc à soutenir
humaniste ça donc aller c'est donc la
signe très fort et j'observe que à
gauche comme à droite s'il n'y a pas eu
effectivement ce souci de mettre en
avant les étiquettes politiques
j'observe en tout cas qu'à gauche il n'y
avait pas beaucoup de roses sur les
affiches si on veut dire que les pétales
était tombé qui reste plus que les
épines
mais vous observerez qui avait pas
souvent de communication avec la rose
une réponse à l'assemblée nationale qui
est à mes côtés
en fait confirmé l'analyse que j'ai
essayé de faire tout à l'heure c'est que
en vérité regarder guillaume larrivé qui
lui avait hissé le pavillon mp il est
perdant ceux qui avaient hissé le
pavillon socialistes sont aussi ils sont
aussi perdants jalili cité christophe
sirugue malheureusement qui a perdu au
premier tour alors qu'il avait je crois
en firent bilan est bien tout cela ça a
un sens c'est que aujourd'hui
évidemment il ya un doute profond à la
fois sur la majorité en place mais il
n'ya pas aussi de confiance renouvelée
sur un projet alternatif qui seraient
portés par là par la droite républicaine
et démocratique
et c'est bien ça la difficulté du temps
d'aujourd'hui le trompe et vous verrez
au moment des décomptes vous allez voir
qu'il ya effectivement un élan autour
autour de l'ump et de lui dit et qui est
un signe en tout cas avant coureurs
avant coureur d'une d'une alternance qui
se prépare allons poser la question
directement à marie claude jarrot qui
nous attend direct de montceau-les-mines
bonsoir et merci d'être en direct sur
france 3 et lui donc ce soir face à
didier mathus comme une réaction votre
satisfaction évidemment leur parler
d'étiquettes
est ce que c'est le fait de masquer plus
ou moins son étiquette qui permet de
remporter une élection en 2014
pas du tout j'ai conduit et je travaille
depuis six ans sur un projet municipal
j'ai une liste j'avais une liste de
policiers deux colistières qui était
très varié avec des compétences une
envie d'agir pour leur ville et pas du
tout une étiquette politique
voilà je les vis depuis le début ça m'a
été beaucoup reproché par mon principal
adversaire mais ça prouve que les gens
nous nous on les monts souviennent
éléments c'est bien nous ont entendus
nous ont compris notre projet était
locale avec des solutions au chômage
avec des solutions à l'économie et avec
des solutions pour retrouver l'industrie
à montceau qui auquel les montcellienne
et les montcelliens ont adhéré question
de l'hymne au mollet bonsoir marie
claude jarrot il doit y avoir quelque
chose de particulier pour vous parce que
on l'expliquait l'ensemble des
bourguignons cette ville elle a été
dirigée par votre père précédemment
bien sûr bien sûr je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure devant mais devant tous les
toutes les personnes réunies devant ma
permanence
bien sûr que j'ai une pensée très émue
très émue et d'ailleurs les plus anciens
démons reviennent aimons ces liens m'ont
dit ton père doit être heureux s'il te
vois mais j'avais aussi inscrit sept
j'ai appris beaucoup de mon père bien
sûr j'ai appris la ténacité la pugnacité
et le goût de l'action et surtout
surtout le fait de pouvoir conduire ce
projet pour les montcellienne éléments
c'est via mon père était très attaché
affectueusement attaché à montceau et il
m'a transmis cela bien que quelle sera
votre première action en tant que maire
de montceau est ce que vous le savez
déjà ce que vous voulez montrer une
rupture
ma première action tant que maire de
montceau je les dis ça sera d'installer
le comité stratégique de pilotage
économie emploi
je vais le faire très vite ça sera aussi
de mettre en place la maison des jeunes
et de la culture au milieu de la ville
dans les ateliers du jour ça sera les
deux premières actions qui seront faites
d'ici d'ici 15 jours
et puis après nous allons nous allons
nous mettre au travail
j'ai pris des engagements pour l'emploi
pour août
et puis notre action aussi sera
communautaire puisqu'il s'agit
maintenant aussi de travailler les
dossiers communautaires ont l'air si
marie claude jarrot en direct de
montceau les mines pour cette première
réaction sur france 3 bourgogne un peu
plus de 20h30 dans cette soirée spéciale
consacrée au deuxième tour des
municipales dijon à présent
traditionnellement vous le savez les
bureaux ferment à 19 heures donc c'était
un petit peu plus tard que l'on a les
résultats sur la capitale bourguignonne
mais avec les réseaux sociaux désormais
il y à des informations qui commencent à
circuler déjà théo ce moment vous êtes
en direct depuis la rédaction de france
3 bourgogne rédaction internet que
peut-on lire sur les réseaux sociaux
théo carneau vous vous souvenez de
barack obama après sa réélection il
avait posté une photo sur twitter
immédiatement
françois rebsamen a essayé de l'imiter
ont regardé 20h03 le message tombe une
photo
sur le compte officiel de françois
rebsamen api avec un petit smiley et une
photo donc de françois rebsamen qui
consultent visiblement des résultats le
message a déjà été retweeté 67 fois et
il annonce donc un succès pour françois
rebsamen dans le même temps le bien
public publiée sur son compte twitter à
dijon alain houpert est monté dans son
bureau interdiction de le suivre ce qui
confirmerait à l'information posté par
françois rebsamen autre message celui
d'arnaud danjean député européen ump
il y à quelques apparatchiks socialiste
monde bourgeois qui ne vivront plus de
leur mandat municipal dès ce soir là
c'est cash c'est par écrit et puis autre
message de christian paul le député
socialiste ne pas transformer cette
défaite électorale en renoncements
démocratique dès lundi agir ne pas subir
ça commence au parlement voilà pour les
premiers messages
merci théo n'hésitez pas à intervenir
dès que vous le souhaitez à cette soirée
c'est sur internet sur les réseaux
sociaux f3 bourgogne sur twitter
bourgogne point france 3 point fr sur
internet pour retrouver l'intégralité de
ses résultats et lilian melet ou eric
sicaud c'est une question à edouard qu'à
20 sur ce résultat alors à dijon on
parle de 53% je ne sais pas si vous avez
les mêmes chiffres connus
écoutez françois rebsamen on va attendre
d'avoir les chiffres définitifs mais
effectivement ce serait une victoire du
maire sortant c'était quand même
relativement prévisible il avait fait je
crois 44% et quelques au premier tour
donc c'était relativement prévisible
j'attends d'avoir les chiffres plus
précis pour voir la débâcle de l'ump et
j'espère avoir progressé un petit peu
dans l'entre-deux-tours nous nous sommes
mobilisés
on parle de 14% pour l'instant mais ce
n'est pas confirmé encore on a 14 % ça
serait une belle progression pour un
entre-deux tours on sait que le front
national n'est pas forcément là le plus
performant donc ça serait une belle
progression je crois que nous avons
mobilisé nous a vu un projet très
crédible nous n'avions pas effectivement
de conseillers municipaux sortants n'y
avait pas de front national à dijon
depuis 2001 donc je crois que nous avons
fait une très belle campagne
les dijonnais vont pouvoir maintenant
nous voir dans l'action c'est à dire
dans l'opposition mais aussi nous
souhaitons être une force effectivement
de propositions le front national n'est
pas là pour s'opposer à tout projet il
peut y avoir des bons projets émanant de
la gauche comme de la droite
l'intérêt commun doit être l'enjeu de
cette opposition constructive que
représentera le front national à dijon
et effectivement je pense au grand dijon
pour l'instant sur les résultats qu'on a
vu la bourgogne est pas une région on va
dire de pointe pour le front national
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
lorca oui je crois que la bourgogne
c'est pas un le terreau du front
national j'allais dire naturel en
revanche on a vu il y a aussi des
comptes records de d'edouard ferrand un
sens quand même avant de oui évidemment
fina mais je crois que l'élection
municipale est une élection
particulièrement local le front national
n'est ce n'est pas son élection favorite
j'allais dire mais on a vu des choses
quand même spectaculaire on l'a vu ce
soir à fréjus où david rachline 25 ans
élu maire de fréjus à béziers avec
robert ménard on l'a vu au premier tour
à hénin-beaumont avec steeve briois
donc il ya quand même une réelle
dynamique le seul parti à progresser en
france aujourd'hui c'est le front
national on voit une débâcle du ps l'ump
la première afa bénéficier de cette
contestation
mais là la seule montée qui existe
réellement c'est celle du front national
aujourd'hui du rassemblement ne m'arrive
pas encore tout à fait en bourgogne
là je parle au niveau national
effectivement après il ya des points au
niveau local où ça n'est pas forcément
le cas
mais au niveau national le seul à monter
c'est bel et bien un front national et
rassemblements bleu marine rémi delattre
une réaction quand même et puis philippe
baumel après mais une réaction sur dijon
ce résultat c'est un fier du jeu ont
effectivement soutenu alain houpert on
vous a vu dans des
des meetings absolument sur dijon
incontestablement françois rebsamen a
bénéficié de son aura personnelle c'est
ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure la
dimension personnelle du candidat
j'observe que 1 ou père a bien amélioré
son score du premier tour puisque
d'après des éléments de ma portée il
ferait cinq points de plus ce qui laisse
qu'ils ont très très faible quand même
pour ce qui reste ce qui reste ainsi qu
un ensemble de candidats qui sont plus à
qui avait fait beaucoup beaucoup de
points quand même je voudrais y la dre
grey je voudrais quand même saluer le
fait qu'il ya une grosse évolution du
score d'alain opère et et on ne peut
effectivement que s'en réjouir
qu'est-ce que c'était le bon candidat
pour vous pour l'ump puisque on sait
qu'il ya eu discussion là dessus je
crois qu'elle a ou père avait
effectivement tout toute légitimité
c'est un parlementaire c'est quelqu'un
qui a été capable de rassembler
je rappelle quand même qu'il ya à 100
mais je rappelle quand même qu'il ya
quelques mois il y avait trois ou quatre
listes qui étaient en lice et que alain
était capable de rassembler tout le
monde et je crois que ça c'est une belle
démo trans mixer alain joyet kevin aidé
à rassembler je l'entends
c'est alain c'est alain houpert qui a
quand même réussi à avoir tous ceux qui
à un moment ou un autre avait pensé fair
nice je vois qu'il a d'ailleurs fait une
liste avec beaucoup de jeunes et je m'en
réjouis
quand je vois anr chance quand je vois
laurent bourguignat quand je verrai
stéphane stéphane chevalier je me dis
voilà il ya des ferments et il ya
effectivement des jeunes qui ce qui se
prépare et qui ont fait une très belle
campagne
est ce que la droite excusez moi mais
est ce que la droite n'a pas raté le
coche quand même parce que quand on voit
le la vague bleue qui submerge la france
actuellement
elle aurait peut-être pu placer
quelqu'un pour 2020 je savais que
c'était très difficile de battre
effectivement françois rebsamen pour les
raisons que vous je pense que
d'ailleurs si on reprenait les écrits de
certains jeux
tout le monde disait que françois
rebsamen aller gagner au premier tour
rappelle quand même que françois
rebsamen a fait que 44% une forte
équation sur sur sa personnalité
et en plus quelqu'un de très engagé au
niveau national et donc c'est déjà là
une belle une belle victoire d'el
victoire pour pour la droite et le
centre locaux et j'ai eu le sentiment
aujourd'hui que françois rebsamen ne
fait pas le score qu'il attendait
d'ailleurs ils avaient fait 56 % si j'ai
bonne mémoire en 2008 et donc on est en
haut néant ressac
on a besoin de revenir sur la situation
de dijon philippe baumel et rapidement
quand même parce que c'est une
exceptionnelle belle victoire ce que
c'est le christ aurait deux semaines
parce que sincèrement avoir un élu
socialiste
autant impliqué à paris par ses
responsabilités au sénat président du
groupe socialiste au sénat
proche de françois hollande tout à fait
qui d'ailleurs l'affirmé le confirme
aujourd'hui réélu avec un score quand
même plus qu'honorable moi sincèrement
on peut pas quand même se glorifier du
score de monsieur ou père qui n'est pas
une progression significative pour la
droite dans cette ville de loin s'en
faut
d'autres d'autres avaient fait mieux
avant lui et je crains qu'avec que ce
score là alors que la vague bleue est
forte
ah non c'est quand même de l'ong jour et
de longues années heureuses pour la
gauche a dijon nous verrons bien rien
n'est jamais acquis
enfin ici on se repose bien évidemment
rien d'ailleurs que monsieur rebsamen a
toujours pris la précaution de prendre
ses distances parfois avec des positions
y compris du chef de l'état il a même en
tant que président du groupe socialiste
au sénat
porter le fer contre des projets de loi
et bavarde écrite et donc il y là il n'y
a pas été avare de critiques et
finalement ça l'a peut-être servi
aujourd'hui nous reviendrons sur dijon
dans un instant mes priorités résultat
vous le savez ce soir en préfecture de
côte-d'or emmanuel pinsonneault avec
d'autres résultats concernant le
département de la côte-d'or emmanuelle
urien définitif encore donc sur dijon
résultats en revanche à auxonne où le
maire sortant raoul langlois est réélu
avec 53 4% des suffrages devant
jean-françois quoiqu'il 46,5 à saint
jean de losne
le sans étiquette michel douich est élu
avec 53% des voix il ne lui avait manqué
que quatre voix au premier tour pour
être élue dès dimanche dernier
il devance annie blandin 47% des
suffrages à plombières les dijon jean
frédéric cours divers droite est élu
avec 56 % des voix il devant murat bayam
22 2% des suffrages le maire sortant
jean-paul s n'arrive qu'en troisième
position avec 21 6% des voix enfin à
semur-en-auxois le maire sortant
philippe guyenot divers droite est
battue 43 2% des suffrages battu par
catherine sadon sans étiquette 56,7 pour
cent des suffrages
merci manuel direction sens à présent
résultats également très attendu le
retour de marie louise fort se
concrétise style basis djaouti
oui oui effectivement c'était attendu
les résultats définitifs nous sont
parvenues donc malade aux formes la
porte l'un porte largement avec 51 3%
des suffrages exprimés et donc largement
en tête évidemment suis derrière
francine weecksteen la candidate sans
étiquette avec 32 9% des suffrages
exprimés et en fait voir ferrand lui
recueille 15 7%
comme attendu donc la vie bascule à
droite est la grande gagnante c'est donc
marie glissement vous l'avez merci
basile gestion directe deux sens nous
repartons à nevers où le futur maire de
nevers nous attend denis thuriau
vainqueur ce soir face à florent sainte
fare garnot bonsoir denis thuriau nous
avons évoqué la situation à ne faire
avec le maire sortant tout à l'heure
l'union a fait la force entre les deux
tours pour vous donner thuriau oui je
peux vous avez tout compris
j'ai entendu monsieur sainte fare garnot
avoir la défaite arrogante moi j'aurai
la victoire précise et humble précise
pourquoi parce lorsque le maire sortant
vient dire je ne comprends pas j'ai
entendu les neuf et reçoit au premier
tour tout allait bien et qu'il reste sur
son sectarisme en disant qu'une liste
sans étiquette c'était forcément une
liste de droite
je me dis qu'il n'a décidément rien
compris à cette élection et je suis
forte est d'entendre remporté un peu
partout en france des listes sans
étiquette de belles victoires savez
notre mouvement n'existait pas il ya
sept mois
nous l'avons enrichi et j'ai accueilli
dans le cadre du deuxième tour
deux autres listes qui nous ont rejoint
sans leur étiquette et qui adhèrent au
projet que je vais mettre en oeuvre avec
eux vous maintenez qu'on ne peut pas
dire que nous l'air a basculé à droite à
moins bien sûr que non on ne verra pas
basculer à droite je suis un homme avec
des valeurs de gauche je l' ai toujours
dit n'a pas besoin d'à partir
d'appartenir pardo parti socialiste pour
être un homme de gauche
par contre j'ai su j'ai pu fédérer des
gens de droite du centre des gens n'ont
marqué politiquement et j'ai multiplié
ce ce rassemblement qui aujourd'hui sera
salutaire
et je peux vous dire qu'il sera
salutaire parce que je connais
énormément de maires de l'agglomération
qui n'attendait que cela
et nous allons enfin sortir du marasme
dans lequel nous étions tombés depuis 43
ans
en tout cas depuis une vingtaine
d'années et
les grands moulins bonsoir denis thuriau
derrière vous on le salue d'ailleurs au
passage on voit guillaume maillard qui
est leader de l'udps est juste derrière
vous ça va se passer comment avec
guillaume maillard et avec monsieur
cordier de l'ump est ce que vous êtes
déjà d'accord sur un certain nombre de
mesures vous avez déjà discuté comment
ça va se passer bonjour oui monsieur
mollet nous étions il ya quelques jours
ensemble donc je pense que nous avons
rappelé que je vous ai dit monsieur
maillard et monsieur cordier ce soir
sont sans étiquette avec moi pour le
projet pour nos verres et
l'agglomération
ils ont adhéré ce n'est pas une alliance
je sais que ça arrange et le parti
socialiste mais monsieur sainte fare
garnot des plus en campagne donc qu'ils
abandonnent donc ce terme
ils ont adhéré à ma liste ils ont adhéré
à mon projet et ce saut ce seront les 85
engagement et plus il en faut je le
crains de nevers à venir qui seront
appliquées c'est un accord qui a été
établie entre nous donc ya pas de
difficultés là dessus vous savez nous
avons su être intelligents nous
rassembler les manifestement quand une
fois j'ai dit que j'aurai la victoire
modeste mais précise nous faisons
quasiment dans le cas d'une triangulaire
nous gagnons à très peu de choses avec
une majorité c'est quand même assez
exceptionnel avec un front national
affaibli et je m'en réjouis donc encore
une fois ça surprend mais les gens qui
ne sont pas suffisamment ouverts
d'esprit et bien tant pis pour eux nous
nous avons su réagir et proposer aux 9
et reçoit une autre voie ils l'ont saisi
à nous d'être à la hauteur et c'est pour
ça je vous disais à moi d'avoir la
victoire humble parce qu'il ya beaucoup
à faire
oui on a posé la question tout à l'heure
à marie claude jarrot à montceau les
mines on va vous la poser à vous aussi
quelle sera votre première mesure est ce
qu'elle sera de l'ordre d'un euro
symbolique pour la ville de ne coûter
pour faire avancer le ce mouvement qui
n'existait pas il ya encore quelques
mois j'ai mis en place des tas de choses
en même temps
donc aujourd'hui il ya urgence il y a
urgence à ville en danger
donc je compte mettre en oeuvre
notamment beaucoup au niveau de
l'agglomération dans le cadre d' écoute
si je peux vous dire que j'ai dû déjà au
téléphone de nombreux maires certains
élus aussi une liste sans étiquette à
varennes vauzelles
voilà une volonté de travailler ensemble
une volonté apaisé et ça ça n'existe pas
dans l'air depuis des années
axa ça va changer la donne sur le plan
économique sur le plan de l'emploi
sur le plan de faire venir des
entreprises et nous allons aller les
chercher
merci denis thuriau pour cette réaction
directe de nevers sur france 3 bourgogne
et nous partons à mâcon pour des
résultats en saône-et-loire à présent
avec damien bouthillier oui bonsoir nous
on y écoute et quelques résultats on va
d'abord commencer par les villes qui
bascule à commencer par cluny
c'est henri bonnyaud le divers droite
qui remporte la mairie à 44 4 contre
jean luc delpeuch le maire sortant quand
6,2 également tournus qui bascule à
droite avec l'eau de roche qui remporte
la mairie 56 5 face à jean legros 43,5
ensuite un résultat sur gueugnon
dominique lotte le socialiste conserve
sa mairie 51,1 contre sylvain rameau
37,8
et puis autant rémy rebeyrotte conserve
également la mairie 51,9 à sa rémission
gros 48,7 et puis un dernier résultat
qui vient de m'arriver celui de
montchanin
jean yves vernochet le socialiste 51,1 %
face à josiane genevois 39,7
on attend bien évidemment d'autres
résultats en préfecture de mâcon à tout
à l'heure damien sens à présent l'yonne
avec la réélection de marie louise fort
qui est en direct depuis sens sur france
3 bourgogne bonsoir marie louise fort
une victoire on ne peut pas éluder le
mot une revanche pour vous
ah non je fonctionne absolument pas en
terme de revanche
chaque aventure électorale est une belle
aventure
nous venons de vivre
en plus d'une belle aventure une
aventure passionnante mais le plus dur
reste à faire puisque nous avons
convaincu par la qualité de l'équipe par
la qualité du programme
maintenant il va falloir convaincre avec
la qualité de l'action c'est peut-être
le plus important alors la revanche non
on n'y pense pas trop on se tourne
plutôt vers l'avenir et faire en sorte
de réussir ce que nous voulons faire
c'est à dire redonner à sens une
gouvernance qu'elle n'a pas depuis des
années qu'elle n'a plus depuis des
années et puis aussi la tirer vers le
haut et tiré vers le haut l'ensemble de
ses habitants et le score que nous
faisons dans l'ensemble des bureaux
montre que ce message a été entendu
et maintenant le challenge ne s'est non
seulement de le faire entendre mais de
le mettre en acte question de lilian
melet pour vous marie louise fort
bonsoir marie louise fort
bonsoir lilian ces deux soirées vous la
connaissez bien mais vous l'avez vécu
dans un sens inverse en 2008
ce jour là vous aviez été battus qu'est
ce qui a changé est ce que c'est le
contexte national est ce que c'est vous
on va écouter si vous êtes dans ce très
plein alors allons-y
mais je crois que ce que j'avais pu
ressentir en 2008 a été largement
effacé lors de la dernière consultation
importante de 2012 c'est à dire le
renouvellement des législatives puisque
manifestement laissé nos nez comme
l'ensemble des et koné de la 3e
circonscription montrait très bien réélu
dans un contexte puisque vous parliez de
contexte de vague rose alors ce soir
c'est une vague bleue
peut-être que ça me fait un point de
plus j'aurais peut-être que 50,1 % des
voix dans une triangulaire mais très
sérieusement je pense que là le travail
aussi la proximité avec les gens payent
et je crois que c'est à force de cela
qu'on peut regagner une partie de la
confiance des électeurs qui ont on le
voit bien cette semaine comme la semaine
passée
boudet quand même de façon trop
importante les urnes et moi ce que je
veux c'est leur montrer que et bien
qu'on soit maire ou député élu on est
avant tout leurs représentants et si je
suis là ce soir à vous parler
eh bien je dirais que c'est parce que ce
matin il y a des gens pleins de gens qui
sont levés qui sont allés mettre leur
bulletin dans l'urne
et je ne parle pas uniquement le culte à
marie louise fort mais les autres aussi
ceux aussi qui ne sont pas venus mais
qui ont fait le scrutin de ce soir et
qui me permette ce soir de m'adresser à
vous mais surtout à eux
vous me pardonnerez dans la question
eric sicaud oui en quelques mots le mari
marie louise fort on a on a parlé de
sens ces derniers mois comme comme de
dallas sur sur yonne tellement c'était
compliqué pour pour la mairie sortant
vous allez jouer quoi l'apaisement
maintenant ah bah écoutez je vous le dis
il ya un temps pour ce qu'on appelle
j'aime pas ce mot d'ailleurs la bataille
électorale
elle s'achève je le répète ça a été une
belle aventure même si parfois on peut
regretter l'agissement de certains dans
ses campagnes mais
maintenant cette page là est tournée et
puis on va écrire une belle une très
belle page pour sens et c'est finalement
ça qu'ils m'apportent faire du sport en
direct de sens pour cette réaction de
paris nice l'a élu ce soir bonne soirée
avec vos militants dans cinq minutes on
fera une synthèse nationale et nous
retrouverons bien sûr pour la suite en
bourgogne ont continué débat avec nos
invités du mollet ben une question à
edouard cavens parce que sans c'était
vraiment des ans alors on n'a pas les
résultats définitifs encore on a entendu
je crois que edouard ferrand et en voile
a priori préparer qu'au premier tour ça
se confirme
mais est ce que dans ce genre de ville
vous avez pas la sensation finalement de
vous plafonné car il ya une vraie
difficulté à aller au delà de cette
position
comme je vous le disais c'est un scrutin
les municipales très compliqué pour le
front national
néanmoins nous avons montré que nous
sommes capables de rassembler de
rassembler pardon il a fait edouard
ferrand presse près de 15% au premier
tour donc il a quand même fait un score
relativement important je crois il va
siéger dans l'opposition au conseil
municipal
il va pouvoir proposer des choses
s'opposer à certaines si elles ne vont
pas dans le sens de l'intérêt général et
je crois que non un plafonnement non on
voit par exemple à dijon si
effectivement je fais 14%
ça montrera que il ya une capacité de
remobilisation de second tour ce qui est
une très bonne chose sur le vote fn si
on le regarde de près notamment à la
lumière de ce qui se passe est passé
déjà au premier tour on voit que le vote
fn dans les très grandes villes
finalement diminuent dans les villes
moyennes ils stagnent
c'est pour moi la marque quand même de
l'échec une stratégie qui était celle de
marine le pen qui a voulu calmer la
faveur des ces municipales nourrir
l'illusion qu'il y aurait triangulation
du paysage politique selon orange à la
droite et la gauche
les cantons c'est 14% sa vie donc on
reste modeste quand même donc il faut
essayer de voir la réalité en france bat
sincèrement le front national n'est pas
apparu pour une majorité de français
quelques canettes quel qu'ait été leur
camp de départ qu'on envoie aux deux
recours dans cette crise grave une
enfant parce que dans le sud un petit
peu plus comme si
la faveur de masques qu'ils se sont mis
sur le bout du nez et qu'elle me
regardait ce qui s'est passé à béziers
ménard n'a jamais avoué qu'ils désirent
de travaux il a rappelé à ses vous qu'il
a martelé pendant sa campagne qu'il
était soutenu par le front national
c'est complètement faux en le front
national que ce n'est qu'elle gagnerait
une quinzaine de villes je pense qu'on
va être entre 5 et 6 voilà là jamais dit
clairement sa marine le pen a
particulièrement martelé pendant la
campagne qu'il aurait 1000 voire un
petit peu plus de conseillers municipaux
l a jamais donné chiffres précis en
termes de mairie parce qu'on sait très
bien qu'on ne peux pas en donner
c'est très compliqué après d'isneauville
voilà qu'on s'en rapprocherait encore
des câlins station malgré tout de ce
parti et à ce qui peut laisser crème
d'ailleurs de mauvais résultats ou de
bons résultats pour le fn aux
européennes surtout vous sauver bien
connu on change de mode de scrutin mais
qu'à ce moment là on est dans un autre
théâtre on verra on verra à ce moment là
mais je ne sens pas non je ne sens pas
de sincérité
c'est le trait pour son ko son camp ce
soir évidemment mais je ne sens pas une
poussée extrême quand même de ce vote
dans une baie risée sur la révélation de
se dérégler
aux aspirations du peuple rémi délatté
vouliez dire à monter oui oui je pense
je pense effectivement que derrière le
vote du front national il ya surtout un
vote d'exaspération on a bien compris
bien sûr par rapport à la politique du
président de la république mais aussi
par rapport aux partis politiques d'une
manière générale et et je crois que
aujourd'hui malgré effectivement le
succès de l'ump et de lui dit il faut
que nous le prenions avec beaucoup
d'humilité parce que d'abord les
différents élus l'ont ils en ont très
bien terminée il faut déjà maintenant
faire le travail et aujourd'hui on est
en train de reconquérir par les communes
la france et prépare effectivement
l'alternance qui bien sûr se
concrétisera surtout en 2017 à
l'occasion des négociations importantes
mais il faut un remaniement il faut des
gestes forts de votre point de vue et du
point de vue des parlementaires faut
d'un gouvernement resséré c'est la bonne
il faut des gestes forts il faut changer
de prix ministre il faut un gouvernement
resserré il faut savoir aussi posé des
conditions par exemple sur un texte va
venir très vite à l'assemblée nationale
qui est le pacte de responsabilité
eh bien je travaille actuellement une
plateforme qui posera un certain nombre
de conditions sociales pour lille a
voulu ouvrir l'état je ne le voterai pas
et d'autre et d'autre et on s'y prépare
on est déjà plusieurs dizaines à on se
réunira d'ailleurs demain soir
l'assemblée nationale en prenant le
risque d'une perte de majorité non en
prenant le risque d'une négociation avec
l'exécutif je pense que le temps du
parlement est venu je ne sais pas s'il
faut changer de premier ministre c'est
pas c'est pas notre sujet c'est au
président de la république d'en décéder
par contre ce que je dis au président de
la république s'il a entendu les
français il faut qu'il change de
politique
merci à tous les trois philippe baumel
rémi delattre et edward qu'avant d'être
venu en direct ce soir on voit sur les
réseaux sociaux que françois rebsamen le
maire de dijon réélu s'exprimerait dans
une quinzaine de minutes on va suivre ça
de près comme toutes les réactions des
hommes politiques ce soir sur twitter f3
bourgogne retrouvez tous les résultats
que l'on vous donne toute cette soirée
sur notre site bourgogne point france 3
point fr nous nous retrouvons d'ici un
petit quart d'heure pour détailler tous
les résultats qui nous parviennent
également en ce moment rester avec nous
sur france 3 au coeur des municipales
tout de suite la soirée se poursuit avec
un point sur la situation en france avec
carole gaessler
et francis letellier a tout de suite